I don't,
I don't know.
I,
I can agree with the general notion.
Yeah.
The ideology of if it's legal,
it's allowed.
Right.
Um,
and I would,
I would argue that,
you know,
what Jack is trying to do with Twitter or I won't say him personally,
but what Twitter is trying to do is what creates like a comfy,
padded neon room for the kids to hang out at another real world is harsh.
You know,
what they're trying to do.
And I don't want to speak for him,
but I think they're trying to engineer the conversation to be more polite and
civil says who exactly.
You know,
who's,
who's definition.
That's a good point.
And that's,
and that's,
that's I,
I see so many of these people who just,
they wield power and they're unaccountable.
Well,
it's also,
you don't recognize the consequences of telling people what they can and can't
do and that it's,
this is a very slippery slope.
You running up a greased hill and people don't like it.
They don't like it.
And,
well the,
the thing is like
when you see something,
like if,
if everything was just open,
what would the conversation would be like if there was no banning,
if there was nothing,
it was just everything was real free speech you would have,
I mean if there was,
if it was impossible,
let's put it this way,
it was impossible to ban someone from any social media platform,
whether it's youtube or Twitter or Instagram.
What would the conversations look like?
How much different would they be and would we maybe have a healthier way of
adjusting?
I think it would be worse,
worse because um,
I could,
I could be temporary or in the long run may be temporary,
but there,
I believe it's called the online inhibition effect.
Basically the opportunity to be anonymous online and the,
and the,
and the distance makes people,
they have no problem being their worst self.
Yeah.
And so I can understand what Twitter wants to do.
They say,
hey,
we need to figure out how we stopped people from being mean all the time.
Right.
Because Twitter is,
it's a hellscape of just mean people saying nothing would mean things.
But it's also again,
because they're anonymous and because it's possible.
But then look,
Alex Jones can can say a bunch of really awful things.
It's his right to do so.
Should it be bent?
He shouldn't.
If so it does.
Does Alex Jones?
Uh,
I'm not,
I don't want a directly accused him cause I don't watch his show.
But if,
if he goes on Twitter and he said something that's deemed to be false shitty
band for that,
no.
If he,
if he challenges a journalist,
should it be banned for that?
No,
because let me tell you,
because he says things about me that aren't true and you shouldn't,
I don't think it should be right.
I think,
and he's saying the things about me and I don't think he should be better.
I think Alex,
I think we should talk,
we should have a conversation.
I watched those videos.
Go ahead.
He's upset,
he's upset and I get it in certain ways.
I get it and he thinks I took a shot at him and I get it.
And I probably did and I shouldn't have.
So,
so here's,
here's the thing.
My point is I don't think you should be banned.
Right?
And it's,
he's doing it at me.
Yeah.
Um,
like I mentioned,
those people from occupy who lie about me all the time,
they've posted the most ridiculous lies about me.
I still don't think it should be banned.
Right.
Does it?
The thing is if you band them and then someone opposes them,
but then someone opposes the people who opposed them and they want them banned
and then you have this fucking war back and forth.
And instead of fighting bad ideas or incorrect ideas with correct or good ideas,
now you just have people present.
Banhammer is left and right and you're just trying to figure out who the
majority is.
So you can side with the biggest group and you're trying to virtue signal and
you're trying to get something that supports your ideology,
whether it's right or left.
So,
so here's the thing with Jones though,
if the people on the left one to argue that he is making the platform worse and,
and horrible,
I understand that.
And I recognize,
well,
that's unfortunate,
right?
This is the real world.
And sometimes people say things you don't like,
but more importantly,
a lot of people argued that when he,
when he said,
you know,
he said something about Sandy Hook,
which again,
I haven't seen the videos,
but they've,
they see he's been sued.
They said that.
He said,
I know it never happened.
So,
so what is fake news to be band?
While many people were saying,
yes,
Facebook needs to ban fake news.
But think about what that means.
It means you're now allowed to be wrong.
Okay.
Because fake news doesn't mean you did it on purpose.
More importantly,
you're not allowed to be stupid.
Well,
here's another thing again in defense of Alex,
one thing that Alex did do is in the future after,
after he was done saying the things that he said about Sandy Hook,
he then said it definitely happened.
So he,
so he corrected his course and there's no,
is there a path for redemption when you correct your course?
And if there's not,
what are we doing?
Cause we're not treating people like human beings.
Then whether it's my low or whether it's anybody.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm sorry to cut you off,
but path to redemption is so fucking critical.
Yes.